what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
final episode of Hot D House of the
Dragon John how are you I am hot and
excited for some more D so ladies and
gentlemen for those who have been
watching with us I want to say thank you
from the bottom of my heart if you can
go ahead strike that like button strike
it down that mean the world to us right
now also um as always falling stretch
and watch along's resync with your own
copy for how to the dragon I tried that
available for a super section rejects
over at our patreon page your support
has been overwhelming and one of the
best ways is support the channel is to
check out some of our apparel I'm much
as we like to call it some of you guys
might not know this we partnered up with
a screen crush and heavy spoilers who
right now has a video up that I'm sure
has 1.4 million views in the last half
hour for House of the dream
um he's absolutely killing it these days
and we partnered up with our shop there
right now heavy spoilers he's got a
shirt for House of the Dragon
representing Team Green but real rejects
we got one representing team black
that's right look he's already getting
all the views so go support us we're
gonna get our shirt now we might not
have that shirt in hand right now
because we're Masters at promoting our
own products we just launched it this
week and we don't but you know what
maybe we'll all get one time here's
here's a photo of a hot guy wearing it
look at him wearing it but any gender
can wear it so yeah guys shop
zeroedition.com
anyway let's watch the final episode now
all right that's what we really want to
do let's see what's going on
not like you
in what way not so
perfect she's not perfect
I've heard it described in the book that
she is way worse
my father looked after me and helped to
prepare me for my duties oh my God it's
come to deliver a message
ready for battle Bucyrus is dead
your father possessed a kind heart
wow so much has happened I forgot she
didn't even know that yeah Egon has been
crowned as his successor
how did viserys die
I could not say so soft-spoken that
[ __ ] of a queen murdered my brother and
stole his throne and you could have
burnt little friend
that war is not mine to begin I only
rushed this morning to you out of
loyalty to my husband and to my house
the greens are coming for you rhaenyra
oh [ __ ] we should leave Dragonstone at
once yeah okay
ever the conscientious one
oh no blood
is coming
of course our term is far from complete
this should not be happening it is
happening stress you know we're kind of
get up get up get up
this show definitely makes birth seem
like the most horrific thing
conscript the dragon Keepers they're
capable Fighters waste no time it will
be done my prince
I hope everyone here remains loyal to
you there's got to be a spy in there
somewhere what's this to be done about
it nothing yet
where is Damon I don't know
gone to Madness gone to plot his War
but leave them with me wow my pulse are
so up
the knuckles are white my mother has
decreed no action be taken while she's
in bed
it's good you're here Young Prince
did you hear what I said
the Ravens looked at
this I shall see it done yeah I'd lose
I'd listen to demon
come with me I'll show you the true
meaning of loyalty oh I'm grateful for
your long service to the crown so I'm
presenting you with a choice
[Music]
let's do a little mutiny
huh
what's the choice
oh you knew you're out to Rainier as
your queen yep oh
if you support yourself speaker now
if you swear fealty now only to later
turn your cloaks huh know that you will
die
[Music]
I was gonna say it looks like no one's
able to do anything
[Music]
what the hell wow
oh
oh
my God
oh how horrible
Jesus Christ
there's a lot yeah
foreign
just seems awful whenever you see this
guy around for a pregnancy
he's like pregnancy of any kind in this
world is a kind of an awful experience
no matter what
did the whole thing herself
bag
that's really that's really brutal and I
can't believe they showed that much
interesting how the first episode
started off with her mother
having a failed delivery here we are
bookending it
seems like the beginning middle and end
even have all been marked by bitter
pregnancies
Eric or Eric
I swear toward the queen
I shall take no wife hold no lands
father no children I shall guard her
Secrets ride at her side and defend her
name and honor
I mean she needed a
significant moment wow
come on Iranians
bend the knee
come on
damn a hell of a shot
this feels almost like Lucid it's like
you're so steeped in all the emotion
and the literal weight of the crown
[Music]
it fell that is very beautiful let's say
I gotta get a hunk of wood and some
candles and build me one of those you
can buy one from Kmart
thank you
thank you Reina
wouldn't hurt to mix up the names George
armor you know
loses a baby immediately gets to work yo
of course owns a power that has not been
seen in this world since the days of old
valyria
dragons
none of our dragons have been to war
there are also unclaimed dragons
she smokes still resides on driftmark oh
[ __ ] Dragonstone has 13 to therefore
I also have a score of eggs incubating
in the dragon Mound
and we could have every green head
mounted on spikes before the Moon Turns
along gallium flying a banner of a
three-headed Green Dragon although the
watchtowers inside the skies
dude Damon is ready he's been waiting
for this it's just gone all in the hyper
Focus mode yeah
here we are again a little jittery there
Damon a lot of mirroring happening this
episode it Rhymes I come at the behest
of The Dowager Queen Alice Lord and
protector of the Seven Kingdoms
where is the princess
really calling back cheese
acknowledge aegon as king and swear a
basins before the iron throat hell no it
says Grace will confirm your possession
of Dragonstone viserys will be confirmed
as the legitimate air to drift Mark and
all the lands and holdings of house
valarian
we'll also be given places of high honor
at court this guy's such a dick rather
feed my sons to the dragons and have
them carry Shields and cups for your
drunken new Serpent of a king yeah
he was anointed by a septum of the faith
before the eyes of thousands every
symbol of legitimacy belongs to him
oh my auto God you own him more hand
than egg of his King concentrator
Grand maester
is this
you're talking like so modern in this
episode
enough of the [ __ ] yeah cut the crap
high tower Queen Alison has not
forgotten the love you once had for each
other no plant need to be spilled the
realm can carry on in peace
Queen Alison deeply awaits your answer
she could have her answer now stopped in
her father's mouth along with his
withered let's send this mum as far
[Music]
no come on
yes Queen King's Landing will have my
answer on the moon
dropping bombs
when dragons flew to war everything
burned I do not wish to rule over a
kingdom of Ash and Bone yeah good boy
father talking my father's dead and he
chose me as his successor
to defend the realm not cast it headlong
into the enemy have declared war
what are you going to do about it
I mean
she's like a spirit that's just haunting
I know
she exists Beyond everything
have fun guys my oath reaches beyond our
personal Ambitions A Song of Ice and
Fire the coming war against the darkness
in the north a conquerors dream
if Sarah shared it with me when he named
to me
no dude my brother was a slave to his
Island's importance oh anything to make
his feckless man appear tough purpose
dreams didn't make us Kings
[Music]
too far man yeah we gotta unpack that
bro
I never told you
oh
wow ouch I mean what do you have to know
I guess no what do you have to know yeah
never consider him to be one to inherit
the throne or maybe Damon thought like
he would be
I mean no he did
he lives he lives his fever has broken
I understand you have a new king
no right to business everyone wait
wait for No One
in our son's death that girl destroys
everything she touches that girl is
holding the round together at present
wow we're nearest the only one who's
demonstrated restraint
[Music]
an unlikely Alliance they both got
poised look always felaria it
wow very sorry about your father
princess
he's a good man
and I your brother
where is Damon
there are other concerns which demanded
the prince's attention he didn't want an
awkward conversation he's much happier
playing with his dragons both Aaron and
Baratheon share blood with my house but
all of them swore Oaths to me as did
house Hightower as did you
yeah
yeah yeah
I did I'm gonna go lay down again this
high tower treason cannot stand
you have the full support of our Fleet
oh my God oh my God
I turn real quick on that chat save up
money for season two we got some battles
to get to uh consult a gold company
could have killed aegon
caution does not mean standing fast I
wish to know who my allies are before I
send them to war now she's playing a
smart man yeah consequence of my near
demise in the stepstones is that we now
control them I took care to fully
Garrison the territory this time oh the
triarchy had been routed
the narrow sea is ours in that grip I
should take me Elise and Patrol the
gullet myself
are we going to war baby
we're going to war we should bear those
mistress dragons can fly faster than
Ravens
and then more convincing yeah intimidate
them and to agree that always works
Prince is right your grace
it's the cast of avatar The Last
Airbender
let's take no part in any fighting swear
it to me no
under the eyes of the seven I swear I
will not kill anyone
I would hope that as men you can find
some common interest
yes as men as half black blonde men yeah
always looks so unsure of yourself man
go to it then
chop chop
this is the first episode with like like
motivating music yeah yeah yeah we gotta
reach further than we've ever dreamed
before all right that's beautiful it's
like Avatar
the James Cameron movie
every Avatar well and this one it's it's
funny this is the most like all the ways
they capture the castle of Dragonstone
it really does look like a big dragon
curled up and especially when they're
having like meeting it's so intimidating
it looks like he's trying to get more
dragons how many dragons at once could
he have loyal to him
[Music]
wow
wow
nice beautiful
psychic connection
Halloween ends
I've seen everyone you've ever dracar
East
you've got this hiccup
I'm real afraid one of these kids are
gonna die yeah I feel like this kid's
about to die
I think they're gonna kill that dragon
foreign
[Music]
monster movie right here
this kid's a goat in the T-Rex pen I'll
bring a message to Lord Boris from the
queen
okay
that's fine that's fine
had a feeling man yeah Don't Do It Eamon
oh so the tracker does not seem to know
who rules it
Jesus
he's so good at that stair Eamon
he's gonna like charge him or some [ __ ]
yeah he's gonna slice his head in half
or something if I do with your mother
[ __ ]
which one of my daughters will you win
I'm already betrothed
so you come with empty hands
I shall take your answer to the queen
my Lord
wait
what what what I came as a messenger not
a warrior I promised my mom fight would
be a little challenge
I want you to put out your eye wow
I would not blind you I plan to make a
gift of it to my mother oh
she's gonna love that then you are
craving as well as a traitor not here
get me all right
I'll not have blood shape beneath my
roof take princess back to his dragon
oh this ain't over
better hurry up and get away man [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh I think amen's gonna find him in the
sky or some [ __ ] yeah most definitely he
only said no Bloodshed under my roof
don't stand around dude just get out of
there
oh no
oh no sorry for this dragon
[ __ ] just waiting for an appear man
it's like every one of these clouds
is that it is not smart man
get above it
there it is
oh still oh he's just laughing
maniacally
wow
oh my God
[Music]
the size to your advantage
[Music]
this is kind of crazy we're doing this
until this looks amazing but [ __ ] this
is scary
no I'm I'm so tense right now
he's saying Vegas too big yeah
I was gonna say I use that size to your
advantage
you can hide and do faster maneuvers
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dude
oh
oh no oh
what is about to happen
oh
God it must be so cold up there
oh
[ __ ] oh wow
oh wow
foreign
[Music]
that was wild yeah
I was and they had no control over their
trash
Damon's returning huh what did he do did
he did he gain some of the feral dragons
or something I think he's given the
message about what happened
this poor woman man
poor dragon
oh what's this look gonna be
yeah right into your soul
oh
holy [ __ ]
wow huh
it's a great last shot
that's crazy yeah
hmm
what's really important is you guys buy
a
shopzeroedition.com get your support in
for team black now you did team black
now in order for us to win this war we
gotta crush the greens yeah if you
haven't read the I don't know what's
I'm like damn all this happened in that
book
all this and more is always the
impression I get all this but way more
messed up
wow we got some [ __ ] to talk about boy
howdy all right guys so in between cuts
as I heard there is so much
I because of this episode you know
there's a little leak happened so I
heard
book readers
really did not like this episode a lot
obviously I didn't know specifics as to
why because I was like well if you can't
tell me because we gotta react to the
episode
so in between cuts I was like
I really like this episode
uh I mean I got like I got like some
some things that I thought were like why
didn't we talk about this yeah is there
some some points that I like we probably
should have had more of a discussion on
on these things
you know the baby
the dragon flashes while the baby is
happening parts of the baby will kind of
look like a dragon yeah we could spend a
little more time in the morning yeah
there's everybody that first found that
yeah there were some conversations that
I was like you know but
still thought it was a great episode
yeah it was gripped the entire time so
uh as I'm so I was like all right I want
to look up because I'm like like crazy
like am I wrong like what's my enjoyment
wrong and it sounds I mean there are
things about
the way the handling of the characters
are that seems to have really pissed off
some people
I don't know everything obviously
because we didn't read the book but uh
we do have a shirt representing the book
team black from a book that I've heard
really inspires people to pick teams
um yeah I heard the
see I thought the aiming moment as
someone who's all we can come from is
like I gotta just kind of throw all that
away anything I just learned in the past
couple minutes I kind of just got to
throw all that away and just talk about
um how we felt about the episode itself
because that matters like we didn't read
the book so you know like I'm not gonna
be bothered by certain things other than
things that I thought on a filmmaking
writing poem like this should have been
done a little better but for the most
part I still thought it was great but
yeah that one of the ending one of the
ending moment Parts is the thing that
clearly is upsetting people looking
online of uh like
uh Veigar Vegas would be there right
yeah
[Music]
it's right there yes there you go Vega
and Eric's yeah there you go um so vegar
all week two three hours of sleep guys
my memory is going to be lapsing a lot
more during this discussion of course
gonna happen during the
House of the Dragon finale but yeah I
think the thing that people was uh
pretty upsetting with people is also the
fact that Eamon didn't directly kill
yeah that it was like he lost control of
the Dragon yeah it becomes there's a lot
apparently that they that they have the
handling of the characters that they did
differently that have really upsetting
people but that's like one of the last
things I read but I don't know I I I
guess like sure it can undercut some of
the
you know the ruthlessness and
determination and the and perhaps it can
lend a little bit more to a situation of
next season of him being like it was an
accident I don't know a lot of looked
pretty intentional for most of it and
then it was like oh [ __ ] no didn't want
to go that far it's like when the
bully's bullying someone and it's like I
didn't mean to kill him yeah
the ledge or something and oh there goes
their spine
um yeah or they got eaten yeah yeah
because uh so far this whole season a
lot of it has been feeling like a lot of
things that have turning points feel
like misunderstandings but in terms of
the episode itself I was gripped by it
uh I like the Lucid quality to it and I
like the
the mournful side that also had this
like uh inspiring angle to it and I
think
yep it's already happening what is the
actress's name who plays renira darson
Emma Darcy I think Emma Darcy has a
wonderful internalized performance where
I could feel there's a lot more thought
processing happening
in arguments and conversations then
she's probably letting on sure and I
really I really like the the pulse of
the way the hostility within characters
was Rising because you would have like
Damon who after learning of the death
has become you know his way of grieving
with this is Revenge they've wronged me
they've wronged us they've wronged the
family they've killed my brother and
he's just becoming a bull bulldog about
it and he's going straight into it
but you know he's also trying to honor
reynera but there's a there's a battle
of
of the Soul here because it doesn't feel
like what rhaenero wants
because he wants to just go in like
let's let's murder let's annihilate
let's get all these dragons together
let's just F everyone up
and she's trying to take a more
calculated approach as raining said
showing resistance and I like that that
tug of because you obviously Rainier
wants to take action but it's a very
much like the the speed of them like is
at odds with each other in the battle
and the approach and how it's tearing
them apart
I was surprised by it man like I
The Game of Thrones World dealing with
audiences is rough could be a rough
Journey for people I understand I
understand then all I think we can do is
go how did we feel about this on its own
I do think some stuff should have been
uh talked about a little bit more like
she lost a baby in a very brutal way
they had these inner splicing moments
with the dragon
and I didn't quite know what to make of
it there were parts of the baby that
look like dragon scale someone was
pointing that out to me and or someone
was pointed out to everyone who will
listen and I
I was like yeah but I thought it could
it just kind of looked like a a dead
baby like that that was born too early
prematurely yeah it didn't it didn't
read explicitly at the time in the
moment as if the baby was like a hybrid
of any kind but then they could cut him
back to the dragon yeah so I didn't know
I thought there was more of an emotional
thing they were doing some type of like
the Dragon one in her but well and you
know like the the obvious symbolism of
like a a mouth but then cutting to a
scaled up mouth with gnarled teeth
during a moment such as birth where you
know I feel like there's a pretty
obvious kind of visual spiritual
metaphor you can draw especially in a
birth as hostile and harsh as this one
is portrayed but they we didn't do any
real
talking about it afterwards uh like no
real like we had a scene where they
grieved about it because that was such a
harsh
brutal like that was
that was you know
wow that is like that that was the I've
had two pregnancy scenes in this in this
like I'm I'm not a woman and that was
hard for me as a man it was a guy just
observing like this is really hard for
me to watch oh sure like the first
episode in this like it is such they are
both very hard scenes and this one also
was just very hard and she lost a baby
like she she lost a child and we're not
really
no one's no one really talks about it
yeah and I mean you again I think you
could argue that part of that has to do
in the immediate moment it feels sort of
like okay it's the compounding effect of
her being so internalized and having to
exert so much Poise because she knows
she's surrounded by people who are quick
to action and you know maybe slow to
thought but at the same time it feels
like
what's been made of her children and
their lineage and the fact that this is
a child with Daemon I feel like there
would be a more pointed yeah emotional
response between the two of them and
again I guess you could argue that they
both close off and go do their own
things when they're grieving but at the
same time that and and viserys there are
lots of Great Moments officers no and
there are great moments that that ring
that Bell to a degree and touch on those
relationships well I think just the
interruption sorry sorry you know I'm
not a big fan of that
um is is like I think the The Grieving
of viserys is shown through Damon's
performance the whole time it is it is
and and I already nourish yourself you
know
yeah yeah and I feel like that's a place
where I could have used maybe another
scene either good or or bad catharsis in
terms of especially with them touching
on this idea that you know viserys
clearly he he showed his true error the
the prophecy The Song of Ice and Fire
and Damon is clearly hurt by that but
but one thing that's made Damon's
character so interesting is that
frequently he will show that as Reckless
as he is as much as he doesn't care
about how much of a detriment he can be
to his family he still very much loves
and cares for his brother especially and
so yeah like because that casts such a
Paul and you have all the political
stuff that it sets in motion but because
of like the last time they all saw him
and these circumstances like yeah I
think the episode in the moment does a
good job of sweeping you up into the
like well we need to act like the
machine is is running now like you know
we there's no time for these emotions
and and yet I think yeah yeah if I one
of the few gripes I would Levy in an
episode like this is that yeah like
especially because the portrayal of
visceras and it's funny that people have
had so many problems with the portrayal
of the characters but unless he's just
you know marketing for HBO like George
RR Martin was like yeah you're like this
is better than my character like I loved
your take on this character and he has
been a character that you know has been
a a very big
highlight is a weird word because he's
had a really harsh Journey but he's a
highlight of the series and so you would
I think expect for the ending of the
season and for you know he will be
remembered in the seasons to come but
this is the time to pay tribute to him
at the end of the you know this part of
the story and so I feel like yeah we
could have used an emotional unpacking
or discussion or something about him
from them specifically
um or somebody like Otto Hightower could
have also mentioned like I get why he
doesn't but somebody could have
mentioned like oh yeah and by the way he
changed his mind on his death bet like
we could have also had that conversation
yeah because people clearly will talk
about that at King's Landing you know
I mean there's a whole lot of big chunks
dedicated to that in the last episode
I guess one part of me
because it's like yeah in the moment I I
actually was thinking that I'm like are
you gonna mention this
and then the other part of me was like
is there a point in mentioning
like would that do anything would they
believe
you know it the only thing I could see
it's it's one of those like I feel like
he could use it as some kind of uh you
know uh mind screw basically to sort of
suggest that even though I'm sure she
probably wouldn't be inclined to believe
it but suggested well this is what he
said as he was dying you know like you
know that that could at least be a
mental manipulation mind you know land
mine tactic or something but at the same
time one thing the season seems out to
do and one thing I think makes sense too
in character is like no we're not gonna
[ __ ] fit around this we're going to you
know again we've already taken action
and you know and this was my plan all
along like I always recognize this guy
as the true air all along and you know
that so I'm not gonna BS you look guys
while I haven't read the book I think I
know exactly how this is going to end
this whole show everyone's gonna be dead
it's just going to be Allison and renera
on the beach and they are just bleeding
out and they are they have both have
knives in their hands she's got the Song
of Ice and Fire dagger and and then
you know like when it's when renera gets
the final steps you know they're slowly
dying it's like they get that you found
like yeah yeah but I still respect you
[ __ ] and uh and then she's like what
were my what were my father's last words
like she says that
and then um she quotes his last words
and then they're like you mean to tell
me
this is all just a big misunderstanding
what that's the thing too that I that
there have definitely been some
significant complaints about and I've
this is like if this just got out to
them like what exactly was said in that
room I feel like that should maybe not
exactly like that but I feel like that
ought to happen because I feel I I
understand that in the in the book it is
different and a lot of things happened
intentionally because here in this
episode it's an accident the way luceris
died uh and you know this whole thing
with uh aegon has been escalated because
of an accident and and to me as a viewer
of the show in isolation that has felt
like a theme a sort of you know these
big plans in this these prophecies and
this you know this Game of Thrones is
all human and it's all based on
perspectives and and what messages are
going where and sometimes the you know
it's a sometimes there's a game of
telephone and sometimes people just
mistake stuff and then that's the
history now and so like
I appreciate that as an idea as a theme
and I have enjoyed it here and I have
sort of
uh uh you know I chalk that moment with
you know viserys you know yeah spouting
out the pieces of the prophecy thinking
he's talking to ramira as part of that
but I can also see why that doesn't feel
as satisfying as like a much more smart
and deliberate choice I guess sure as it
sounds like the book does instead of
some of these things I don't know
out of town we get involved with the
discourse
I find it fun I've found it interesting
to hear what book readers say because I
respect it I can't I would never be like
hey it's different you know different
medium because I've had that with my own
experiences with other properties like
it can be hard to divorce yourself from
it and and feel like it's I think that
the thing is like what if it's doing it
on both levels like okay it's an insult
to the source of the book and then it's
also
it's also like contradicting or
undermining things that came before in
the actual show you know yeah like
that's what I think like okay and I got
a real problem you know
um because yeah it's like that I love I
love the I love it a lot about it you
know like rain is kind of just cracked
me up in this episode
God just give her the throne please
Spirit walking around observing she's
like it's not my War but I'm gonna kick
it here because I'm literally kind of
leaning here um so I'm a very
subconscious level I'm very much leaning
towards joining her side and that's why
I didn't murder them last episode but I
keep sticking around and even when uh uh
oh Micah Corliss uh wakes up first thing
I'm gonna start doing has been like you
know she's actually giving her [ __ ]
together real well yeah maybe we should
have learned I got your back yep should
have killed that kid sorry oh boy God
and I love the two of them like and even
the way that turns around like
immediately because they're talking
about like I don't know who we're gonna
lie ourselves with and the second he
gets in that room he's like well
yeah I'm gonna die a treason if I say
anything else but also yeah the scene
when I the scene when uh Damon uh
uh has is arguing with rhaenera and he
chokes her that's a hell of a turning
point that's that's like that's HBO
right there that's it it's not TV you
can't have it's HBO can't have HBO if
you're male leading actors not
[Laughter]
[Music]
every pitch begins with that Mark of a
good HBO show right there every HBO
story is just about how we got to the
moment when some of the male leads the
male lead becomes domestically violent
that's that's when you know you're
watching HBO show welcome back to the
domestic violence Network
um no that
that is the turning point though for
sure I think I think the
the thing that was kind of baffling to
me is I thought they said some statement
about like no don't worry we cut back on
like the harming of women and there's
only like really like Runner is like
really hurt a lot in this I think they
that that like if I didn't hear that I
think I don't think I would have thought
of that
I mean obviously not
um I think they meant they cut down on
on a the amount of gratuitous brought
those scenes and then B how many of
those things escalate toward violence
got it got it got it got it okay yeah I
think it's more like no this is still a
cruel world for women yeah you know yeah
it's cruel for everyone um yeah so but
that but that moment what I thought was
neat about it was
because rhaenera doesn't is not really
fighting him she's not even struggling
like to really like it's not like
hitting him or whatever
she's like using the moment to listen to
him and and observe what he's saying
yeah so when he's done choking her
she flips it on her like you have no
idea what I'm talking about
he didn't see you he didn't really see
you as a viable successor yeah like
never did oh wow he really did believe
in me yeah
yeah that's what I think I thought that
was neat I mean I I feel like you know
there's there's some subjects here
within this episode alone that I'm like
as as a guy I have my opinion of from
observing but I'm sure like on a on a
woman's perspective it could be very
different how some of these scenes are
received you know
so
yeah uh I thought the the final it was
really obvious like I didn't we didn't
read the book it's really obvious to
freaking just uh
like the second he shows up and and it's
just a horror movies
stormy night
you're just like okay
they're definitely dead uh it was still
a really tense moment and I thought it
was beautiful like I don't recall Game
of Thrones even doing a dragon scene of
that like when would they have that uh
like a this dragon writing through the
night and that is and it's like medieval
fantasy
landscape like it was gorgeous to look
at and was intense and there was that
part of me that was like I hope not
um and then like the reveal of agar like
riding above them in the clouds it was
terrifying like there's terrifying I
felt bad for the kid I felt like he was
going to die the second they were like
don't kill anyone just message me yes I
mean not that that's as much
like there's a part of me that thinks
part of that maneuver was a little bit
silly honestly because it's like you're
you're sending them into the lines then
yeah they're showing up a [ __ ] Dragon
too you know you're literally sending
them to people you know have since
broken their oath and are just expecting
that it will be fine wasn't it just
yesterday when Eamon was ready to like
kick your kid's ass and what's to say
like the second he shows up at the end
and vegar Rears her head like you're
like oh yeah well of course they would
have people around here they're the
their the the source of all power right
now in the in the realm so like they
would have people probably wherever all
their allies are because they would
expect be expect like I think she would
I think it would be reasonable to expect
that uh someone like reniro would know
that there would probably be occupation
or you know soldiers or something from
the crown wherever she's going to send
these people because if their allegiance
is in question of course they're they're
going to know that too and want to
solidify it you know yeah no I mean
apparently it happens in the book but I
think the I mean just a day so that's
not on the show so that's not a problem
so yeah take that video
message you know how smart are you now
book
JK the thing is you know what though the
thing a while ago I was listening to
something and and and you know the the
critics said basically like the instead
of reading a book and then watching a
movie what he likes to do instead is do
what the other the opposite way around
and and this experience and then hearing
not so much like with the end of The
Game of Thrones series because I think
that went the way it did for other
reasons but something like this I have
thoroughly enjoyed for all 10 episodes
and have you know like this feels like
really gripping High Caliber event TV
still for me and it also still gets me
excited for the idea of diving into the
book at some point you know and and and
seeing the level of detail change and
and all of that the expansive experience
won't do it no not until the show's over
no well yeah I mean that's yeah for an
ongoing experience like this yeah I
don't I don't want to spoil anything
that might be rearranged out of context
but it does make me curious messages
would be cool to catch Easter eggs in
the moment and stuff and then be like
here's what they changed and here's
where it's gonna lead to or maybe not
now they can't be there yeah yeah I I
like not knowing um yeah absolutely
especially when seeing how upsetting it
is
I was like
quite liked it I will say that generally
this show has been every episode has
gotten like a better for me okay it
started off great and it just kept
getting greater and greater and greater
and this was the first time I was like
not greater like this is not my favorite
like like every new episode was becoming
like oh that's a contender for favorite
episode like that's the way it was sort
of going for me but this one
um definitely like there were there were
some some stuff about the last episode
that made me go
I'm not sure
so great this sort of felt like the last
and first episode of a season to me
in in a sense yeah yeah I felt like they
were really trying to wrap a lot up yeah
and I was like why are we rapping stuff
like we're just set up yeah absolutely
because I think you could still end on
the same kind of note without having to
wrap all that stuff up and leave some of
that for later when we can expand on it
yeah if it was there am I giving you
reminders of when people try to wrap a
series up well I'm like we're not
wrapping up a series wrapping up a
season right now but you're also you're
leaving it open to continue it for next
season so
it's it's not like you have to end it in
a way of
we might not come back so you know we'll
wrap it all like that's not what you're
doing so some stuff I thought was like
no let's deal with like the they just
saw this series yeah let's have the
craving moments they just lost a baby
like let's deal with this let's let's go
into the conversations it's been a it's
been one of the best parts about this
show and they do take the time to have
those conversations for a show that I
feel like has mastered time jump they
weirdly skip over a lot of it seems like
very important things to to deal with
with our characters that seem to be kind
of like
this happens oh I'm sad
moving on
as opposed to something looming you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I think
that I I guess I would agree with that
assessment yeah that like I like this
episode a lot a lot of things about it
it wouldn't be yeah that continuous rise
and and partly because I feel like
another thing that has made the show so
good on top of the grip on time jumping
is the balance between again the the big
world political stakes and the small
personal Stakes the weight of the crown
and all of its Pursuits and this episode
felt like it zoomed out more than it
zoomed in and it left a lot of the
zoomed in stuff I agree with that yeah
in the performances so luckily you have
Emma DARS and you have Matt Smith and
people who can carry that around with
them but yeah I feel like the writing
didn't do such a good job at balancing
the two here
but uh
for this one was cool I always love
toilets I don't remember what happened
well and two it's I think it is
interesting and I would love to hear
more opinions about the fact that like I
feel like the show has been marked like
you pointed out there's the bookends of
the birth with you know uh uh uh
raniera's mother uh uh you know in the
early you know the first episode and
then in the middle you get not only a a
raniera birth but you also get Lena and
that whole thing and then you get this
and uh and and and two like the whole
Lane of thing not that it's like
directly tied to this but there is a
very heavy Dragon element there so it's
like there there are these interesting
symmetries and these interesting you
know themes they've peppered throughout
yeah I'm not sure the purpose of it
other than the I mean it's like the
Symmetry is obvious yeah because I mean
obviously correlate it it's like first
one is renera's Mom viserys dealing with
this uh that's like really tied to
radera and then because that person
could have been the boy right yeah the
the King for a Day there for a day right
so got his own funeral pyre that was uh
more linked to Rainer and then the next
one was more linked to Damon and then
now this is about both of them yeah you
know so it's like yeah one two three
commas this is the true like it's the
trilogy I wanted
well and then two you have the the one
right near a birth which is like a weird
display of strength where she's like
damn it I'm marching in Dallas this film
with my baby and here it's oh yeah
there's at Birth too yeah yeah yeah and
then here you flip that around where
it's like no one I am doing this alone
and I'm doing it on my terms and and and
yeah it's like a much more sickly kind
of gollumy moment in a way
so it's like it's
never before have I seen his season so
marked by traumatic birthing scenes well
I think this episode's
um pulse was interesting like it was a
bit weird like a bit Lucid at times
sometimes very uh sometimes felt very
like definitely focused on the immediate
moment but I think it was there were
there were some shortcomings in the
season wrap-up syndrome
um and I because because there was
plenty of times where I was like man
this is really intense just I'm gearing
up and learning information and getting
ready to go like this is intense I'm so
craving pizza right now by the way like
this is so weird this is so intense
um you said a flash of Pizza
House pepperoni wow I could see the
crusted the cheese is she's here and I
just felt and screaming come over
in my oven yeah
but it was it was it was good it was it
was a good one
um I I I I liked it I liked it a lot it
was a different it was very different
than the other ones and I think
sometimes because they didn't have I got
the impression that sometimes they
didn't have enough run time to do the
dialogue scenes so they would try to
really make up for it with like mood and
atmosphere and tone and like The
Grieving scenes like just really no no
one talked just really show it you know
and to be fair to a degree it is a time
for for you know Stone silence and
reflective silence so I don't begrudge
the episode those tones either
and auto man he shows up man what a dick
every time well now more than ever Jesus
master plan has come to fruition he is
like all about himself right now
Mr Coffee yeah no if there's anyone I
want to see die it's him horribly I love
watching him but he's also the one I'm
like man you show up and just you talk
like you're so pompous
you're so arrogant I just want you to
die like smug is the word yeah you're a
smug [ __ ] seldom have I experienced a
character where like when he when he
gets you know he relieved the first time
of being hand and they send him away
rarest Decades of Mormon damn I'm kind
of sad to see him go and then the second
he shows back up I'm like I hope someone
kills him yeah but he showed up here I
was like just go for it yeah just kill
him you know what's coming you know
what's gonna happen yeah yeah yeah I'm
also I'm curious to to see how this sits
with me and how part of me thinks it's
cool that they ended the season on
here's one episode only from one
perspective and one episode only from
the other and part of me wonders if
there could be some kind of maybe
lacking Symmetry and that we should have
some kind of I don't know side by side
at the very end but I don't know I
thought it was kind of a unique Choice
given how much each episode is usually
shown you a bit of everything which I
think I think doing that really helps
establish the Divide yeah yeah of Team
Green versus Team blacks I I think that
that was a great choice damn you were
saying something
no no I don't think I really needed them
to come back around to say anything
including both sides like I think I
think you're probably yeah it's like you
leave us off with just how bad things
have gotten at home in the last one and
then this one it's yeah here's here is
the fight for next season and here is
you know from our main perspective from
Rainier's perspective you know what is
to come I think
you know like Eamonn having like vague
like Eric's accidentally attacked like
Eric's out of
um luceris's control attacking
didn't bother me um vegar attacking out
of eamon's control didn't bother me
it was only when I heard
why I bothered people that I was like oh
yeah I guess that would have been a
stronger Choice see in the moment I was
at the moment I didn't I didn't mind I
was like oh [ __ ] that's terrible and
even though they're both you know Dragon
Riders to different degrees you know how
can in control are they really their
kids to some degree still you know so in
that moment I bought it for those
various reasons so then yeah yeah but
when hearing that I like I like the
choice more of Amen was like uh Eamonn
if Eamon was
[Music]
um it it is stronger to me if aemond is
as opposed to like ah great another
another mistake he's just upgrade it
yeah another mistake that's gonna either
make this character try and get more
sentimental or just become much worse
because I still feel like to me it
doesn't undercut that Eamonn made a
mistake still that this is still eamon's
mistake he's still the one who chose to
like relentlessly pursue this guy out in
this weather but then ride that dragon
and he was like see the whole time I
thought he was trying to kill him yeah
so like
um you know as opposed to just get the
eye it the whole time I was convinced he
was just trying to kill him okay and so
this is still his fault you know like
because like he oh he can't walk away
going it's not my fault he's like you
can't walk away say that even though it
was vegar who didn't listen to him you
can't say that because I'm like well you
gotta pushed it to this point man yeah
you invited this 100 I'm sure Vegas
probably only the impression that
doesn't support his job was you wanted
that kid to believe he was about to die
and probably his dragon as well so what
do you expect yeah yeah I still I still
felt like it was his it was his fault
regardless not like he's not he's not
revoked of responsibility like I still
feel like no he's pretty much like 99.9
responsible for what happened so I think
that's why like I like the choice of him
just going headstrong into it
um but you know if he tries to like do a
whole episode of like copying out of it
like it was an accident which I don't
think I don't see him it almost seems
like in this world Eamon would just be
like uh yeah I killed him yeah I guess I
did yeah sure you know he should have
just let me take the eye it's his fault
you should have just let me exact my
equal revenge and that's it
instead he got himself eight
and and burned up all right guys well
House of dragon
[Music]
you know it's like I think the thing
that has me worried is that
the the show's been so positively
received yeah and then when this leaked
it was like oh my God the book readers
are all like pissed off yeah yeah yeah
yeah they would be the ones who were
like no no I don't care about the
viewing experience I've got to go right
in and see what this is I think I don't
wanna I don't want to do this again
we've all been enjoying it please please
I know there's some who don't just let
us but it seem like everyone was happy
let us have one satisfying finale I
can't do this to my soul again I know
what's season two gonna be like is it
gonna be a disaster no Miguel sapochnic
maybe it is a bigger deal
uh alrighty I hope it it's I hope it's
good maybe they'll take some some notes
from the internet we'll see you guys
thanks for being here much love see you
in two years
[Music]